my agents rang me up and said a producer
wanted to talk to me about doing a
Formula One story in the 1970s and I
well but the phone call was booked for
two days later and so the next day I
decided to Google it a bit you know to
avoid painful silences on the phone call
with the producer and I found this story
and I suddenly thought this is riveting
and I love these two characters and it
goes somehow to the core of my life
because I was living in Vienna at the
time and I knew Nicky a little bit then
the phone call came on the Wednesday and
he turned out he wanted to write he
wanted to make a film about Jackie
Stewart who is a Scottish Formula One
a great champion but you know not you
know not somebody that inspires a film
and so I we went our separate ways and I
did this one I don't know if they're
still doing theirs but you know this one
I went Nicki and Nicki and I became very
close and we met about 30 or 40 times
and and Ron and I brought this stage Ron
it was initially Paul Greengrass but and
then Paul and Ron switched roles and Ron
and I were looking for who the right
James Hunt could be and I was always
convicted Daniel to play Nicky yeah and
Ron and I from the get-go were
passionate about it being a German
playing Nicky it was really a problem we
couldn't find an Englishman good-looking
enough to play James Hunt and so when
when when Chris was good enough and
brave enough to do an audition tape and
sent it to Ron we were both completely
blown away and it was it was done and
dusted straight away I had to first of
all learn all sorts of things like like
getting some experience in a racecar I
spent over a month and Vienna to get the
accent right because it was crucial for
me to speak with an Austrian accent not
with the German accent because it has a
lot more irony and cockiness and
arrogance and then that's just
indigenous to because the audrina money
er than us which is not that difficult
but and and then every day I was waiting
for a phone Nikki's call and then one
day at six o'clock in the morning he
called me and he said well I guess we
have to meet no and I said yes that
would be great okay it just bring him
to Vienna in case we don't like each
other you can piss off right away so I
flew to Vienna with my little handbag
and then from that moment on he
supported me all the way through and I
was very happy that you know he was
willing to talk about all all these
sensitive things we talked about death
and fear and overcoming fear and it was
really opened and yeah very supportive
did you go through similar kinds of
preparation in terms of learning how to
drive a car at 170 miles an hour yeah
and if we walk it up to that speed but
we we went fast enough to I mean we did
a boot camp about three or four weeks
and got up to speeds that enough to sort
of go oh this could end badly if we
don't kind of pay attention and pull
back and he did and it did Wow almost
there was um you tell the story well I
had an accident a wheel came off on my
Ferrari and I made a spin and it was
really like I was quite concerned for a
couple of seconds that bounced bounced
on me on the axle and was inches from
going all the way of earning through the
top of the karts okay Andrew you saw
this as it took place here it was before
we started filming is when these guys
were doing the driver training so
fortunately didn't get on camera yeah in
my paranoid German brain I immediately
thought it was Chris I read like
manipulating at the car I was tightening
the bolts in on the wheels that there
will nuts actually I had nothing to do
with it wasn't sabotage I had a I had a
bit of a dream about getting combining
hi Hollywood and in the shape of wrong
with all his expertise and filmmaking
and storytelling but somehow making it
feel rougher and more kinetic and more
raw and cheaper and and so this is where
Andrew came in andrew is like our indie
producer God in in the UK you know here
he's the business partner and lifelong
producer of Michael Winterbottom and
great friends with all the Danny Boyle
crew whatever and he put together a
basically the entire production is made
by Andrea Arnold Danny Boyle
Michael Winterbottom's people with the
Pope of Hollywood sitting on
of it all you know with you know with as
it were wrong with this you know
straight out of the very very mainstream
American filmmaking system and I loved
the idea of bringing these two things
together so that you would have both the
satisfaction of a mainstream movie but
but some of the stylistic you know edge
that you would get from a younger more
progressive crew yeah oh you're working
with him on your next project er yeah
we're doing a film called in the heart
of the sea which is a book and it's the
true events that inspired Herman
Melville to write Moby Dick and yeah I'm
lucky enough to work with Ron again
could you both talk about your
experiences working with him as a
director again this was a very different
style for him mm well he's been an actor
so he is a the way he communicates
communicates with you as an actor it's
just fantastic because he knows exactly
what you need you know he gives you the
right amount of confidence and attention
and support and and it was interesting
to see how enthusiastic and and and and
fresh he was because one is one of these
directors who jumps from genre to genre
right now so it for him to make this
movie was a completely new experience so
the energy was was was incredible onset
you know yes sir there was no need for a
director's chair because he was jumping
around all the time and there and he let
us participate in everything you know
from now he's the greatest and the from
you know an actor's point of view you
want to feel you know on set that
environment is safe and you know you're
allowed to explore things and and
there's not kind of a single target your
twenty hidden and Ron dumb Ron creates
that every single day with everybody
every department I think that it's such
a freeing way to work and such a space
where you know they're you're allowed to
file and you throw out a bunch of things
and you know something lands great we're
moving on even if we came up with genius
ideas you know yeah he's too polite to
say that's [ __ ] he just said it
that's very interesting I won't do it
yeah it's yeah yeah very interesting why
saying no yeah well one point Peter said
that you know II thought maybe we could
do it with
Racing at all because it's really a
character story and and so it was it was
a kind of a moveable feast and one of
the reasons that Paul left the project
Paul was concerned about whether he
could get enough money to be able to do
the way he wanted to tell the story but
um it was a bit of a juggling act you
could make this film for anywhere in
between a sliding scale between sort of
1 million dollars which is how they made
Senna and and probably three hundred
million dollars and recreate every
single Grand Prix and Paul wanted to be
closer to the other end and but you know
and and I knew that you know once we
cast Daniel we would only be able to get
a few pennies because he was a German